NARRATOR: In the
south, a 14-ton bread
truck is impaled on rocks.
Thord and Andrzej
were attempting
to lift it clear until it
threatened to crash back
down with Thord underneath.
[bleep] that bloody
left bar right there.
[tools clanging]
You know, we have to be
careful here because this
is nothing to be kidding with.
THORD: We're putting them
here under the wheel.
So if something happened it
will not go so long down,
so there is space for us.
We always take the safe first.
[truck idling]
NARRATOR: Andrzej
brings in a heavy duty
airbag capable of
lifting 30 tons
to bolster the trolley jacks.
Using an electric compressor,
he has to inflate it quickly
to stabilize the truck.
[airbag inflating]
NARRATOR: With everyone
clear they try again
to haul out the huge rocks.
[mechanical whirring]
[intense music playing]
[rock slamming]
Woohoo!
[truck idling]
[hopeful music playing]
[mechanical whirring]
NARRATOR: Because the airbag
holds up the bread truck,
it should be a piece of cake
to pull out the last few rocks.
THORD: Now we have
taken some very
big stones away under the
truck, so now we are very happy.
[laughter]
[boisterous yell]
NARRATOR: But this job
is only half-baked.
The bread truck is still stuck.
Thord and Andrzej now have
to winch it up onto the road.
Take it out from this place,
go for the garage, and repair.
[truck idling]
NARRATOR: Inching it
forward on wooden tracks,
Thord must not let
the truck slip.
[creaking noises]
The road's still open, so Thord
must avoid holding up traffic.
[intense music playing]
THORD: My plan is always
working and this time too.
We can work in dream team.
[laughter]
Today is the best
people working together.
So now Andrzej go to garage and
then, maybe Monday, it repair.
Then he can drive a new
trip with the bread then.
[inaudible]